story's going to have a lot of
reverberations here shocking new report
on the nursing home scandal in new york
involving deaths caused by covet 19
across the entire state brian yenis is
on this from the beginning in fact brian
the news
is not favorable here it's a stunning
report about 50 percent of the deaths
may be higher than has what been
reported what do you have now
hello yeah bill good morning this is a
bombshell report
76 page preliminary report on the
investigation conducted by the office of
the attorney general here in new york
leticia james which found that the
deaths
in in nursing homes assisted living
facilities of covet 19
in the state were actually under counted
by as much as 50 percent the report also
found that nursing home facilities
lacked proper ppe
as well as testing for covid19
which led to the increased risk risk of
death of those people in these long-term
care facilities
the investigation also found that some
nursing homes are to blame too for their
lack of compliance
and poor service more than 20 nursing
homes are now
under investigation also in terms of the
under counting of deaths
in the investigation there was this
example take a look at this
in one example 11 confirmed or presumed
deaths were counted in one nursing home
the actual number of deaths were 40.
more than 8 000 people have died of
covet 19 in nursing homes
in the state that is the official count
but families have long
suspected that the death tolls were far
larger than that remember more than 42
000 people have died of covet in new
york that's the largest
number in the country now under governor
andrew cuomo the state was
only counting those who died of covet 19
inside the facilities they were not
counting those who died of covet 19
while they were at the hospital the
state also found
that the march 2020 new york state
department of health guidance to nursing
homes and long-term care facilities
requiring them to accept covet 19
infected patients
that were just released from the
hospitals may have increased
the may have increased deaths and this
is despite governor andrew cuomo's
claims
uh that they conducted a study that
found that there was no correlation
between that doh
order and the number of deaths in a
statement in the release it says quote
government guidance requiring the
admission of covid19 patients into
nursing homes
may have put residents at increased risk
of harm
in some facilities and may have obscured
the data
available to assess that risk now
governor andrew cuomo's office has said
they were simply following
federal guidelines to ensure that no one
was denied access
to these long-term care facilities but
again he has been under incredible
pressure uh from critics and families
who
point to that order as the reason why
there were so many deaths in the
facilities now in a statement
attorney general letitia james said this
quote as the pandemic and our
investigations continue
it is imperative that we understand it
is imperative that we understand why the
residents of nursing homes in new york
suffered as at such an alarming rate the
big question now bill is what happens
next and in this report
the attorney general calls out the fact
that
frankly under a march 23rd 2020 immunity
clause that was signed by the governor
a lot of these nursing home facilities
and those responsible for these deaths
fall under immunity she's asking the new
york governor and the state
to uh to overturn that immunity clause
that those
uh can be you know so that people can be
held responsible for these thousands of
deaths but
there is going to be a lot of questions
for the governor families have been
asking for a long time
where was the data they believed that
there were more deaths than that were
actually being counted
and they believed that that order in
march of 2020 ordering people back into
res
into nursing homes despite the fact they
were infected with kova 19
caused more deaths and this report at
least preliminarily is saying
it looks that way and we're going to
continue to invest in indictment really
stunning stuff brian thank you quick
reporting on that brian yennis thank you
the governor was talking about this just
this week the governor
was on did an interview in which he said
it was federal incompetence
and incompetent government kills people
more people died than needed to die in
covet that's the truth well
indeed it is the other thing is remember
this governor wrote a book about how
well he did in a pandemic response it
got it became a bestseller
and then he won an emmy for his
briefings for briefings
and now you have families they weren't
there to be able to hold their loved
ones hands they weren't able to have a
funeral
and now they're finding this out what
brian's reporting at the end there is
important to emphasize
these were coveted patients who were
being treated at local hospitals here in
new york
and the order came out that said once
they're released from the hospital the
nursing home
must take them back in well these
nursing centers with all the elderly
they were the most vulnerable
of all at any point in covet 19
especially during march and april of
last year it's a really stunning
indictment where we've reached out to
the ag hopefully we get our honor very
soon we'd love to have her and
talk to him great show today thank you
for being here